hey what's going on its bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you how are you how are
you everybody oh my goodness I am down
to my last couple gigs of the year other
than a couple of benefits or whatever
the last couple gigs of the air got
Madison Square Garden coming up on
November 7th and then the 8th 9th and
10th I'm gonna be at at the Chicago
theater and then that's it old freckles
is done for the year other than a
thousand other [ __ ] local [ __ ]
things that I'm doing yes so November
7th I'll be at Madison Square Garden but
I'm gonna be doing a tune up show
wink-wink nudge-nudge at a comedy club
somewhere in Manhattan on November 5th a
comedy club that might be on the west
side it might be a comedy club a West
Side comedy club November 5th
I don't know might be running my hour
who knows I might be there I'm gonna be
there on November 5th and I love that
place I love the people that run it I'm
gonna be there I'm gonna be bouncing
around all over Manhattan having a great
time getting ready to do that show and
I'm gonna do the MSG with virzi and Joe
bartnick I'm gonna record that night
this time we're gonna get right and I am
really really really really looking
forward to that what else what else did
I have to announce here before the
throwback there will be a teaser of the
the first uninformed patreon episode
patreon goes live no vent ly November
5th
next Monday at wwp tree on Comm slash
bar I got all this extra backstage [ __ ]
at the forum I'm flying in helicopters
I'm showing you sanam some of my beauty
secrets skincare stupid [ __ ]
um and that is all a nope you know what
we might have a special guest on this
podcast a special guests that I'm
married to that I love to death who's
the best thing that ever happened me but
she still you know pissed me off today
and I've been doing such a good job not
having arguments with her and I kind of
shook it off and then she said something
else to me in the kitchen and I had to
you know you know there are moments we
just have to be like hey you know you
can't talk to me like that alright I'm
over here I'm being a swell guy and and
you know so you should be being a
sweetheart and I'm just not I'm not
feeling that you know feeling like
Pompey and like a swell guy and someone
else is not being a sweetheart then then
I become a jerk-off oh look who just
came in the person I was talking about
I'm doing the math here the lovely Nia
everybody the greatest thing that ever
happened to me though yeah although if
you behave the way you did this morning
every time you'd be one of the worst
things that ever happened to me Oh
doesn't that sound sincere everybody
apologize all right are you gonna sit
down on the couch
so anyways I'm sitting there you know
mine in my own bidness and Danny there
you go you sit down you sat down so Neil
hi how are you this is gonna be a little
therapy session but you know you know
what I mean okay I get I lovely daughter
up I guess you said him to my face I got
these things a little too loud you said
to my evidently face you said that you
go you know I come upstairs right I
worked out yet oh I work out where
they're from I put all this [ __ ] hey
quit breathin into the mic they're
breathing yeah I put all somebody's in
it [ __ ] put that clip on a loop and
jerk off to it
that's how creepy
Internet is and have fun have fun with
that
anyways I put all this [ __ ] from the kid
Halloween party broke that all down put
in the back of my try notice that it was
yeah get all of that I went to the gym
right yeah enough being a hell of a guy
go upstairs right ol adorable cutie face
doesn't want to get up yeah yep she
likes to sleep like somebody I know I
think that's so adorable we got this
thing now we come in stomp times now and
she doesn't you take the blanket off her
and she has this little mischievous grin
and she pulls the blanket no not feeling
it yeah that's cute I just want to stay
here for another couple of 20 minutes so
anyway see you leave chilly it's
probably a vibe today oh so right I get
her out of bed you leave and evidently
at some point you said to me hey bill
put her in this outfit hey bill put her
in this outfit how many times did you
say is once you told me in the kitchen
you said you said it twice I said it to
you you said I said to you twice and you
said it to my what now I said to my face
that's what you said it you like that
cop you like the cop and Reservoir Dogs
buddy I am gonna shoot you and you don't
put that outfit on our daughter so I
didn't hear and I saw that Bruins
sweatshirt I put on that you know yeah
can you make more noise I'm sorry sorry
sorry what are you doing I'm done I'm
here I'm present
I don't know understand why your mic is
so frigging loud it's like literally
you're just moving your hand it's making
it do all this stuff alright anyways yes
so in any way sit and then you're
sitting there right she had a poopy
diaper I handled all of that crap
literally right and then you come in you
like wait yeah
really doing I'm just like oh I'm sorry
she goes yeah well why would you do that
well well she can go to wherever that
whatever event she's going to win this
right you're like yeah but you know it's
not gonna be as breathable that's what I
I put out so then he leaves so I was
like I by the way she's standing there
adorable eating the homemade pumpkin
bread that I'm a sweet guy I'm a made
guy I'm a made guy yeah I'm a swell guy
right so then you leave so what do I own
as points if you guys can recognize
where that quote is from oh come on
that's it easy I'm a guy just pull it a
little away from your mom yeah maybe
like right here caps what's the
difference now here a little more closer
there you go will you keep adjusting the
level that you touch that's fine anyways
so then I change I change her into the
outfit that you said and you come
walking in like nothing happened
so I jokingly say hey dad thanks for
putting on the other outfit and you just
like why do I have to say thanks I told
you to put her put her in that outfit
twice to your face then you walked out
yes in defence in defense shout out to
uh what's was it oh my god fat sack that
shelf for transforming fat cells and to
McDowell's yeah if I'm coming to him
sorry I just accidentally hit that
friggin button there reach reaching for
my smoothie where the hell were we
Oh fat cells fat cells turned it into
what a McDowell's and then they also had
like on the side of the building they
had a big printout and as his employee
of the month
Akim and as a picture of you know Eddie
Murphy from the movie and who's that and
it's Jerry Ferrara that's right that's
right Jerry Ferrara why did you have to
throw that in Hollywood huh you can't
just say it's owned by him you always
got to do that anyways because I'm a
nice about the person so then yeah so
then you just like yeah I told you that
twice to you right
say like that do your face that's how
you just said in the case I saw your
face so I don't yell anymore that's my
thing I kiss keep saying that bah ha ha
ha ha now until you're a [ __ ] jerk
did something mean it is it is there's a
reason human beings are able to yell
because God knew that some of them that
he made were jerks
so anyways then I I walk I'm the king of
muttering now I'll put the outfit on and
you get a [ __ ] thank you very and I
[ __ ] go downstairs and I'm making a
smoothie all right and the lead and the
thing is not supposed to turn on the
food processors not supposed to turn on
unless you have the whole thing closed
and it turned on anyways and stuff is
going all over the place and then you
come over you're like it's like all over
my shirt so I give you the look you
deserved I thought it was like leaking
from the top I didn't think you realized
that it was coming no not from the top
from the bottom so I didn't I don't know
I didn't realize well you most of that
look was because of your your thing
upstairs in the face right so then what
downstairs and I was just like hey you
know not for nothing
yeah I didn't appreciate you could have
said thank you you're like why do I have
to say thank you bill I told you two
times to your face that's what you said
I was just like yeah and then that's
that's when I I snapped I still was
saying effing GD not using the actual
words right right right I was just like
you know yeah you're not gonna talk to
me like that I'm not gonna be a
sweetheart and then be talked to like a
jerk
because then I become a jerk off I'll
become a typical Staten Island jerk off
I loved that I loved it for people never
saw that we watched some reality show
and there was this woman from Staten
Island true life I'm a Staten Island
girl okay
like the MTV show true life I'm a blank
this is true life I'm a staff so she
went into New York the city into the
city she went to a club she was dancing
with a guy she had a longer Island iced
tea she's dancing with this guy and as
dancing with her he's like soda grabbing
his girlfriend - yeah and she's like are
you like you like grabbing on my
girlfriend like why you dance with me
and the guys like what with a date and
then they just cut to her outside that
Club and she goes that was your typical
Staten Island jerk oh no I thought he
says well we're not married or someone
like there what are we married something
like that something to that effect
mm-hmm anyways he was going for the
threesome you just met her yeah
got a respect that there's no loyalty in
the club oh [ __ ] I think that's gotta be
I think that's gotta be on a t-shirt but
you gotta say that you gotta say da in
duck club no can't say th 'if you say th
e then you think maybe it's a white club
like what are you talking about the
White House I know but like I said it's
so overdone when people write duh
whatever on t-shirts it's just like oil
has the finger on the pulse social media
yeah oh it is yeah what are the top
three emojis the top C emojis are the
face the one where the eyes are closed
the mouth is kind of like like oh my god
I can't believe this is happening face
these are my top three I love that one I
also love the finger on the chin one hmm
one and then I also like the one eyebrow
raised those are my faves you want to
hear mine and the crying laughing of
course you want to hit my what do you I
have one my the thumbs up that covers
everything yeah yes I heard you on point
yeah non-committal that sounds good hey
Bill you know one of the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've ever met I thought I'd let
you know that thumbs up
speaking of which yes I got a text
message so wait do you forgive me for ya
and I'll tell you and I'll tell you why
they do apologize it was
it was over the top and I'll tell you
why cuz I'm done I'm done being the the
angry guy I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
I'm not that's too much of my life has
gone by I'm on like [ __ ] the 13th hole
here what am i doing right fifty years
old that's a golf reference but I don't
know what that thirteen well there's
only eight and there's only eighteen
holes
oh so you only have five more holes
lives 150 okay you live to 80 that's a
great run although I am drinking no
we're gonna live longer remember I'm
calling it right now you are gonna be
like the Don Rickles of your generation
and we're gonna like live in Las Vegas
you and I we're gonna live in Las Vegas
for like however long they want to book
you for like all we want to give them a
year a year residency at this place
we're gonna live in Vegas we're gonna
live in one of those like obnoxious like
penthouse five room suites in Vegas it
sounds horrible
why is it so horrible you're gonna go
downstairs and be like hey and jokes old
people tell I'm gonna be like shopping
at Caesars and having lunch at the same
place every day they're gonna know it's
gonna be great kidding me it's gonna be
so much fun you're gonna shop at Caesars
yep yep cuz they have all the stores
yeah there's just one store in Caesars
so it's like all the stores that you
know yeah every time we go to Vegas
we're there for about 36 hours you're
like I got to get the [ __ ] out of here
that's true but I feel like I think
you're gonna live on the strip in Las
Vegas and this this is how you're gonna
go out your golden years so I'm not
going anywhere for a while but God God
willing come wait I'm just saying that
that would just be fun like if you're 80
and I'm 70 yeah why wouldn't we just
like live in Vegas why not yeah I'm not
going out like that Nia and no one's
saying you're going out but like the
chick there's a very high dose didn't
live in [ __ ] Vegas did he do Vegas
yeah he did Vegas and then he got the
[ __ ] out of there he got another gig you
think you're gonna be on the road like
that when you're 80 years old yeah first
of all I I retire at some point and just
do like a nice local gig yeah it doesn't
have to be in Las Vegas I'm a [ __ ]
redhead Nia I'm not gonna be it
global warming by the time I'm 8 he's
gonna be 140 degrees out in the world
are you doing stand-up out in the desert
like no you're inside all those old
people that live in Vegas they stay
inside the whole time and Erica yeah and
one heat wave like five of them died
yeah because I can't make it over to
their [ __ ] air-conditioned I know but
those are probably the ones who aren't
doing so well financially so they can't
so they don't matter
Wow like you know chances are they're in
places that you have good that's what
I'll close with because I wear a silly
grin the moment you come into view
there's a lot of older people who live
in Las Vegas bill so I'm just saying
you're gonna be an AC and you're gonna
be an air-conditioning yeah I'm not
gonna be there I have a plan okay it is
your plan huh and I'm probably know what
this plan is yeah well it doesn't
involve [ __ ] living in it shopping
its Caesars my god
living in Las Vegas in some obnoxious
[ __ ] penthouse yeah looking at all
look at them all down there honey get
away from the window yes skin cancer
your ass that point will be sleeping in
different Suites Jesus Christ what was
the text that you were about to talk
about Oh
thumbs up my favorite emojis oh the
thumbs up all right so this is thing
going on on the internet right now cuz
all Yankee fans are pissed at not all
the infant but a lot of Yankee fans are
pissed at Boston at the Boston Red Sox
fans that are talking [ __ ] right all
right there's different kinds of sports
fans this is a sports fan that goes hey
man great series you sons of [ __ ] you
beat us whatever and you leave it at
that then there's the middle guys who
just won't be friends with anybody who's
a fan of another team and then there's
the worst of the worst
which are just the [ __ ] talk and
[ __ ] who talk [ __ ] [ __ ] all the
time
and then when their team loses if you
can find them because they go into
hiding right to give them the [ __ ] back
that they deserve they then act as
though they don't understand where this
is coming from and have the audacity to
be like Oh
class act class act right so I don't
engage in any of it okay right like
there's some hilarious stuff on the
internet right now with um you know [ __ ]
talk and Red Sox fans at shit-talking
Yankee fans one of them's like that one
of them woke up few Yankee fans had the
audacity to say the Red Sox bought the
World Series
oh they're mad huh well it's just like
well where did we learn how to do that
you [ __ ] they suspended twenty
million a year for like twenty years
and this is the first like couple last
couple years they've gone with their
farm system which is brilliant and
they're gonna get another one and
they're gonna get another one soon is is
what I think as much as I don't want
that to happen as a Red Sox fan
I'm also you know fan of baseball I love
what they're doing so it's just like all
you guys all they're doing is
stockpiling their cash and they're gonna
go out and they're gonna spend a ton of
[ __ ] money and they're gonna come out
with it whatever the hell you need to
spend now to 228 million is that what it
was that what we spent and then also go
on real classy real classy talking [ __ ]
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba if the Yankees won we
wouldn't have said [ __ ] about Red Sox
fans it's like the [ __ ] you wouldn't the
[ __ ] you wouldn't I remember when you
want him and what you said I was there I
don't know what you guys are talking
about you guys threw beer in the face of
one of our relievers this year stop
acting like you're a clown ow my face in
the face so anyways this was the day
after I'm not gonna say who this person
is but he's a very emotional person and
I love him and I've done his podcast and
he's done my podcast and he's one of the
funniest people I know I love this guy
but he's out of his [ __ ] mind he
sends me a text at 12:34 p.m. he writes
you know Pedro Martinez sucks big fat
elephant [ __ ] still he still suckin
elephant dicks so I write back thanks so
and so exclamation point god bless
exclamation point right and he just
keeps going he goes he doesn't care he
doesn't clean them either he just sucks
elephant kook only person still rocking
a jheri curl so then I write back the
number 11 and he's still in the middle
of his rant he goes I'm a bad guy now
cuz he
because he still sucks [ __ ] and then he
takes the bait and he goes 11 what and I
go Championships five Super Bowls four
World Series one NBA title one Stanley
Cup four teams 17 years you'll tell your
grandchildren about it and then he just
writes back you've changed man and then
he continues whatever man
you didn't bring back that animal
Schilling and his fake bloody socks and
I just never responded so I don't under
thick I don't I'm done Nia you don't
understand it like I'm gonna have
relapses like when you bait me two times
in the face right that might send me
back but I am done with this [ __ ] he
just rolled your eyes you know what it
is Nia you know you know in your heart
of hearts if I [ __ ] beat this thing
you got nothing on me you do I work hard
and make a greater lutely
abso-fucking-lutely are you kidding me -
shut your cute little face up I love you
to death near I love you to death but
you know you know something can you quit
yawning into the microphone dental
office waiting room all right so long
yeah I know when people missed you and I
missed you
well I'm back baby all right I need to I
need to read some advertising here this
first one's called nobody that's the
sound of your voice right as I'm walking
out the door to go do something fun I
just hear you from upstairs
swing by is always the opposite
direction 20 [ __ ] miles I wasn't asked
you to bring home some bananas
way back from the gym but I thought
better of it oh you did I still would
have done it you know but I was like no
he's always saying that I always ask him
to guy asked you something the other day
cuz I'm like [ __ ] this this is gonna be
equal I asked you what my buddies were
coming up for the World Series is oh you
skipped a few steps there what did I
skip you asked me to go get some beer
and you said okay oh Jesus and then I
yeah and then a half hour later you're
still laying there and I'm like Mia you
gotta go get that beer and you're like
oh you were serious it's like yeah we're
serious my robe when you told me so I
was like you know I got a half hour to
get out of the room not to mention you
it was 1:00 in the afternoon [ __ ]
laying around like Cruella De Vil all
right it was a Sunday no wasn't yeah why
it wasn't was it a Saturday it was
Saturday can you please put that back
look at it put that down no I can't I
can't look at stuff that's in here now
it's covered no it's it's a [ __ ]
that's an Elvin Jones Modern Drummer
magazine I see that it's a very like you
know look it's obviously a collector's
item abut I can't like pick it up and
look at it I wasn't gonna take it out of
the packaging all right can I just read
the advertising yeah all right nobody
wants to feel like they're overpaying
while shopping online but did you know
there's an easy way to always get the
lowest price it's called I don't know
why they picked this name honey is a
free shopping tool that automatically
saves you money money yeah by searching
the internet for the best promo codes
whenever you shop online that means you
get the best deals without ever trying
on your favorite sites what whatever
trying on that means you get the best
deals without even trying on your
favorite sites like Amazon eBay Walmart
Best Buy new egg new egg Etsy Groupon
and more in fact honey yes our listeners
of this podcast an average of forty six
dollars and eight cents does it does it
all for you it always applies the
biggest discount right at checkout honey
has saved over Dez has over ten million
members and over a hundred thousand
five-star reviews there's no reason not
to add to your browser today get honey
for free and join honey calm / / that's
two words
join honey dot-com / / the easiest way
to save money while shopping online all
right
Jolly shave club dude Dollar Shave Club
has everything you need to look feel and
smell your best doctor and you never
have to go to the store don't have to
don't go to the store swing by the path
you get me a rack of Bud Light and a
little [ __ ] a little nip there that's
because they deliver everything you need
right to you dua
they keep you fully stocked on what you
use so don't see you don't run out
here's how it works Dollar Shave Club
has everything you need to get ready no
matter what you're getting ready for
they have you covered head to toe for
your hair your skin your face you name
it they have it and they have this new
program where they automatically keep
you stopped stocked up on the products
you need you determine what you want
when you want it and it shows right up
to your door for once a month
what for once a month - once every six
months however you want to do it plus
with their handsome discount can you
quit breathing into the mic like a
[ __ ] pug you know though Plus with
their handsome discount the more you buy
the more you save
and right now Dali shade Club has a
bunch of status sets you can try for
just five bucks like their oral care kit
after that the restock box ships regular
size products at the regular price
get your status set for just $5 right
now at dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / what do we got
left - more - more oh look who it is
simply safe simply safe Nia wouldn't you
like to sit around your house and feel
simply safe here's why I'm a fan of
simply safe home security go send it
honey
if a storm takes out your power simply
safe is ready and intruder cuts your
phone line simply safe is ready say they
destroy your keypad or siren Nia simply
thief will still get you help the help
you need make sure maybe it's overkill
maybe you don't need to be ready for
every worst-case scenario love how
they're dragging you back to your own
[ __ ] well why wouldn't I want to be but
that's what makes simply safe home
security system so great it's always
ready simply save could cost an arm and
a leg but it doesn't instead they only
charge you what's fea 24/7 professional
security monitored monitoring is just
$14.99 a month and there are no
contracts no hidden fees
I like no contracts and then what they
when they don't show up I don't know you
guys are no paperwork I'm not so kidding
they're not gonna do it I recommend
simply safe to everyone I know you got
to check it out go to simply safe calm /
bird that's s impl
I sa Fe bird comm simply safe calm to
protect your home and family today
simply safe bird comm sorry I forgot the
bird part lastly but not leastly / oh
sure everybody loves a donkey but have
you ever thought about owning one at
borough comp kidding borough makes
clever uncompromising furniture for
modern life at home did you realize this
Nia and as the days get shorter and the
weather gets colder you know you're
gonna be spending more time at home on
and on and on the couch and on and on
and got all hip-hop there make sure that
that times well spent with the sofa from
borough handmade in North Carolina Nia
made in America by immigrants has a
built-in chagiya in case that sofa
blocks a wall outlet
you like that Nia yeah Nia can you just
could you be involved here this is it
money don't want me to like to breathe
you don't want me like whatever no you
can pretty just honestly a
microspectrophotometer here yeah that
sounds great there go you got to be that
person okay yeah great yeah yeah hey you
got the charger built-in to the sofa
yeah it's amazing and what's more
borough is designed for comfort exactly
17 inches off the ground because that's
the average height from the bottom of a
person's foot to the back of their knee
includes a built-in USB charger so you
never get to have to get up that's great
what's things I read again okay let's do
that read again alright I like that you
said that's great but I want more
emotion this time okay all right
includes a built-in USB charger so you
never have to get up that's great that's
okay now I didn't just just okay no but
that's good acting but I want late-night
TV people have fallen asleep you got to
get him to buy a sofa 2:45 morning all
right they're ready got it I'm ready
here we go
includes a built-in USB charger so you
never even have to get up that's great
oh and even more introducing for his new
line of pillows come on keep the energy
up yeah and throws for unique
collections help you decide in your
style that is terrible at the eff
ethically manufactured manufactured
ethically manufactured with fair trade
and good weave certification ah you can
get your living room ready for fall and
save $75 $75 it's right $75 on a new
sofa by visiting borough comm / / for
your $75 order shipping is fast and it's
free that's burrow bu rrow comm / bird
gets $75 off your
order sorry hora thanks again to burrow
for supporting the show when uh what a
[ __ ] do they throw at me
wait how's that spelled again beat you
rrow if this isn't the greatest couch
with a plug-in phone charger you ever
sat on alright what are we up to here 31
minutes near just like that yeah I swear
to God I love you to death and I'm done
getting into fights with you have you
noticed that I've been trying to say yes
you know the old me would have taken
that bait you know what this is that's
not even a you thing I've been married
too [ __ ] long to ever expect a
compliment I know what the deal is well
you should be that's what it's gonna be
and this is what I want them better late
than never
this is what is what I want you to do
near I want you to continue to not work
on yourself oh yes yes and I'm gonna
become I'm gonna become such a good
person people are going to start
whispering to me working on myself you
know that I'm working on myself you stop
putting words in my mouth what are you
Trump I'm great
you know I'm great on myself people have
said no one's worked harder on
themselves that I have I am the greatest
work around myself ever anyways hey I
want to thank everybody that's coming
out to Madison Square Garden I'm
recording that night and please come
down and I have a couple of glasses of
booze get all [ __ ] that's right
loosen up I'm gonna have a great time
I'm [ __ ] going up knee I've been
going hard
than ever on stage just because of all
of this they keep asking I wish I could
be there for a Madison Square Garden I
know it's gonna be amazing cuz the forum
was literally the best show I've ever
seen you do and I've known you for years
and I'd like to count yep it's like the
best show I have ever seen you do and
I've seen you do like amazing shows but
that farm one was like even when I talk
to people about it now they'll just say
it's just from the moment we walked in
the door like they're just the whole
energy was electric and I think the
crowd was really excited you had a great
crowd that night like it was just that
the crowd was was really really yeah it
was just great energy and like Joe and
Dean were both just on their a game like
it was just well Joe and Dean walked out
there like they were doing a spot at the
store which is like how you have to be
right yeah no they just went out there
and they were just like hey what's up
and just yeah well I was like alright
well let our intimidated by the venue I
guess if they're not nervous why should
I be no I'm very uh ya know it's a
humbling experience ya go out there just
like I don't know if I ever get to do
this again so I'm playing yes that's
that's like your new thing now yeah that
you play the drums and and do then jam
and then you know like I feel like you
shake all the nerves out of you by doing
yeah you just go when you just make a
ton of noise yeah I did that at the
garden in Boston I'm gonna do it at MSG
again and you know oh I played for like
almost three hours my shoulder was
killing me that's so great that they let
you do that though yeah well at first I
thought that they would think that now
what is this [ __ ] doing that but then
it's like this bands in there all the
time tuning up yeah and I think that
they get a kick out of the fact that uh
that we're acting like we want a radio
contest rather than coming in there like
oh another arena right yeah we come here
like I mean that's all we do I saw
Queens of the Stone Age here yeah just
right just freaked out the whole time
I'm there wait are we not gonna talk
about the party yesterday oh how much
you crushed that frigging party we had
the
second annual kid Halloween baby
Halloween baby Halloween party I know
how nightclubs are 21 and over this is
this was 2 years and under it was
adorable first of all but no it was it
was really nice the one little kid
dressed like a hedgehog oh my god big to
little kids dressed like hedgehogs there
was two hedgehogs at the party all I
know I thought that was gonna be
friction yeah
Snoopy the one family odds one family
came dressed as Charlie Brown and Lucy
that was the parents and then Snoopy was
the baby
that we had the tired the tired
I loved the tires that parents showed up
in just their bathrobes and pajamas in
the kid also in his pajamas you went out
got us all skeleton costume oh my god we
talked about your skeleton Gus my
skeleton slash camp outfit that you got
me it was a giant onesie with feet and
hands it wasn't clubs it was all sewed
into it there was no option there was no
option then we found out later on that
night that there was actually like this
ski mask thing that you were supposed to
put over your head like are you serious
it was definitely freaky yes and then
you had the most craziest joke ever
yeah last night like oh Jesus Christ ago
there was a [ __ ] ski mask thing with
that and then you laughed you said put
that on and [ __ ] me and I was even even
that made me uncomfortable and I know
you were [ __ ] joking obviously but I
was like Jesus Christ Nia was missing
was the zipper mouth yeah yeah that was
a one in Gunnar oh my god horrible but
no that was
was a fun time thank you so much for
your help all right is this okay I'm
gonna take you to a mic class at some
point you literally have it laying
horizontal across your chest I know
could I be like any lazier right now
yeah I have my energy I'm comfortable
now finally in a comfortable spot I get
the blanket
I feel good yeah he's what we supposed
to be working right now you suppose
painting people and you're sitting there
like a they took vacations together all
right
no but the the caterers were amazing all
the food was amazing and and thank you
Twitter for your your playlist
suggestions I thanked people on Twitter
but I want to thank you guys again oh
you crushed it it's a lot of good ideas
you had all this great music and then
all of a sudden would just go into like
thriller yeah Michael Jackson and
everybody get all psyched with that and
then it'd be soon that would be like
baby how does that song go
once that's in your head you don't
that's done it's done and I had three
different versions oh are you serious
yeah I don't remember baby shark/doo doo
doo doo de be shocked did you know
that's not our mommy it doesn't go to do
to do to do you know it doesn't how does
it go it doesn't do that
you didn't even you didn't even know
what this song was until I played it so
how do you know how it goes how does it
go then I don't remember but it doesn't
go like that well there's a few
different versions there's a slower one
that goes baby
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo baby
sharp dude - dude dude that's the one
baby she wasn't baby shark/doo doo doo
doo de doo prefer shut your face doo doo
doo doo doo doo doodoo doodoo face
there's a fast one though that was the
first one I heard baby that was the
first one I heard oh well maybe it works
with that voice and then I heard
baby and then there's an R&B version one
that I play at the party as well
I'm just firing on all cylinders all
their spicy margaritas
who were those bad boys all kinds of
delicious food we had like the toys and
the games out for the kids you know it
was a good time it was a good time yeah
and now it's over
I have to go return all those tables and
chairs how can I help you with the
little kid chairs and they were coloring
and putting stickers on construction
paper it was so cute I like little kids
at that age like they just like there'll
be two little kids just looking each
other another kid just runs up she's a
fast and then just stops and they just
stare at each other and then they all
just run to go diminish to something you
know our our neighbor texted me and she
was asking how the party was she has
older kids and she was like you probably
had a much more controlled situation
because her kids are older and she's
like when they get older once it's like
four and up she's like every party is
completely insane because just their
energy is all over the place anyway and
then they have candy and she was like
please enjoy like the kind of controlled
atmosphere that you have with this age
group but I was like no I know that's
why I wanted to keep it to 1-under cuz
they're just insane right like don't you
think no I wasn't aware of any of this
storm front coming yeah I mean whatever
happens I know that me in my siblings
did tenfold to my mother so I have it
coming all right that's the podcast now
I go now we're gonna be listening to a
clip of uninformed the first one and I
don't know how many years ten years
that's going to be on the patreon page
that is going to be debuting November
5th November 5th excuse me I just burped
November 5th and you're gonna talk to me
about microphone etiquette you know
right see that guys that's how it works
I want to get along with your wife just
to learn that phrase you know you're
right
all right that's it have a wonderful
weekend you [ __ ] and I'll talk to you
on Monday
[Music]
[Applause]
never one of those ones dude if I could
go back in time I've worked in so many
kitchens I've never seen so many
jailbird I've never seen why don't you
get over and [ __ ] wash some I've
never working agent I've never seen so
many fat men do so much cocaine [ __ ]
I know I've told you this story
I got a classic one manager right the
manager where I worked I was a busboy so
ice-t-- have to mop up around the oyster
and they had like the black and white
tiles like the old improv used to have
right so I'm mopping that up and always
be a [ __ ] mess yeah and I would have
to mop up and clean the men's room and
the women's room in the women's room
always look like you know like the
Yankees just won the World Series it was
just like paper a ticker tape
all over there it was it was a [ __ ]
mess in there guys it was just stay
pissed all over the place so I go in
there to clean the bathroom and my
manager is in there he's got the water
on full-blast and he's brushing his
teeth while puking the water keep going
then he just kept brushing his teeth and
I was sitting there I didn't know what
to do his [ __ ] teeth and he's just so
and then he played it off going like oh
you know it was brushing my teeth
sometimes it makes me gag and I'm
thinking well don't [ __ ] Jam the
toothbrush down your throat you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it wasn't till I was only 19
right so what is it until years later
that I was like oh he was [ __ ]
hungover he just was [ __ ] puking up
alcohol and he was probably standing
there puking then I came in and then he
was just trying to act like he was
brushing his teeth like I wasn't gonna
notice that he was [ __ ] puking but I
was standing there all over the brush
that guy was that guy was so funny I'm
every go for T believe it or not he ends
up getting fired right he goes yeah he
gets fired and then he gets a job
managing another restaurant as they all
do yeah
you walked out into the floor and an
Eightball fell out of your pocket you're
fired
and then like dude they won't even go
across town they'd be across the [ __ ]
like the strip mall so this guy ends up
getting another job making way more
money and I swear to God he showed up
like a week later with this new job he
had bought a brand new car and he came
over to peacock like we gave a [ __ ] and
he pulled up with some white Subaru
sports cars I can't even what the [ __ ]
he had he just kick and he just was
sitting there at the [ __ ] bar with
this cat ate the canary smile on his
face I said hey man how you doing I say
is that your car out day he's like yeah
want to drive it and he slid the keys
across the bar Jesus Christ yeah I swear
to god it was like I was in a Roadhouse
the dude restaurant workers are like
dirty cops they just get shuffled off oh
yeah during another Sukkot precinct
oh yeah once you're in you're in dude it
doesn't matter
[Music]
the Monday board a podcast is back on I
too
you can't you can't you can't you can't
you can't what's going on it's bill burr
it's the money my podcast that was the
worst [ __ ] mix ever done I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm in my pajamas what do you
want from me the Monday morning podcast
for Monday November 1st oh my god it's
almost Thanksgiving this [ __ ] is
back on iTunes so everybody relax you
[ __ ] smartphones relax you can
download it it is back I don't know why
it's back I don't know why it went away
it went away like somebody's drunk
mother a couple of months you know
couple of months back she started
drinking this Shiva 3 huh
got a little tipsy she went out to the
bar and she never came back and then all
of a sudden she just comes walking back
into our lives
no apology no nothing ma where the [ __ ]
you been
Gerry just leave it alone all right
she's sober yeah I don't know what I
don't know what happened with [ __ ]
iTunes I don't know what I said I don't
know what I did there was no explanation
actually there was an explanation but
it's too [ __ ] boring to get into I
used the wrong punctuation some sort of
quotes when I put the money more no I
use an asterisk you know little Barry
Bonds little Sammy Sosa little Mark
McGwire little Roger Maris action when I
went to go post it and then they just
they just took me off you know and like
some mean little 7th grade girl they
just refused to talk to me we were BFFs
and it was [ __ ] over and there was no
reason complete overreaction so for last
[ __ ] 35 days or so we would like do
what the [ __ ] you know I thought we were
friends so anyways we're back we're back
on iTunes and if you guys have you know
your smartphones or whatever the hell it
is you can download it you can download
it to your iPod you can go right back to
[ __ ] off at work isn't that great
isn't that phenomenal
doesn't that make you feel good
uh as you can see I kind of sound
excited this is like one of these these
episodes where I'm going to be a little
manic because not only am I excited that
the I the podcast is back on iTunes also
freaking out because I have a ton of
[ __ ] that I have to do today so to be
honest with you guys after this
wonderful intro I'm just here to tell
you I really don't have time for you
[ __ ] this week what do you think
about that huh um all right what are we
gonna talk about this week let's let's
let's open the page let's open the page
Nia closing the door cuz I'm being too
loud what it what's the matter Nia
afraid of the funny
she's in a mood but aren't they always
yeah I got a smile and it really annoyed
me this weekend I was I was in st. Louis
meet me in st. Louie Louie meet me at
the fair don't tell me the lights are
shining anyplace but there
we will dance the hootchy-kootchy you
will be something else that is a sexual
innuendo oh but it's the 19 [ __ ] 40s
so we can't talk about bangin um sorry
Mitch Miller baby was my first album
sing along with Mitch in the gang and I
just found out that [ __ ] just
died that son of a [ __ ] was like 90
something years old still putting
Grecian formula and his beard god bless
him um not Jesus why did I sing that
stupid [ __ ] song I forget what the
hell I was gonna talk about let's go
back let's try to go back into the
memory bank I was in st. Louis this week
and I did a benefit for the children
John carnies carnies kids I did that uh
Friday night Saturday night I did the
funny bone two shows that the funny bone
I want to thank everybody who showed up
had a wonderful time out there and if
you guys want to go back in time and
reach back into a little bit of
Americana that you feel was lost during
the last 20 years of horrific moves I've
got an idea let's come up with NAFTA
let's send all the manufacturing out of
this [ __ ] country and then someday we
want it back we got to compete with
sweatshop labor that sound like good
idea I think that's a good [ __ ] idea
I have an idea let's have a war [ __ ]
let's have two wars at the same [ __ ]
time how we gonna pay for it yeah we'll
borrow money from China that sounds good
to me
why am i blaming it on southerners I
don't know why
I don't know why cuz the last two guys
were from Arkansas and then the other
guy was from Texas you know you realized
before Obama the last two presidents
should have been on the Food Network on
one of those barbecue offs you know
trying to compete who has the best
[ __ ] sauce mine's vinegar-based and
his his it more molasses okay that's
that sweet stuff you put that sweet
stuff on cuz you don't know how to cook
good place mate you're not good you know
how to cook good pace me you don't need
to go that sweet stuff you clearly a bit
Boehner garland I come from the
foothills North Carolina we use we use
vinegar start you start using that then
that sweet stuff you're talking about
Kansas City um anyway so if you want to
if you want to reach back into America a
little bit and just stop if you have
children and you want them to see what
this country used to be like back in the
day when you could eat cheeseburgers and
french fries and a [ __ ] drinkin
goddamn chocolate malt and somehow not
end up being a fat [ __ ] because there
wasn't all these goddamn preservatives
in it alright isn't that what it makes
you a fat how come it people used to eat
like no one knew [ __ ] about nutrition in
the 1950s yet everybody kind of seemed
like they were in shape
y'know granite they will [ __ ] openly
racist and grabbing their Secretary's
ass every five seconds but they were in
much better shape if you want to go back
into time go to st. Louis because st.
Louis is one of the few places I have
been to and the last eight years that
you can still smoke in comedy clubs and
you could smoke in bars and people just
light up and and I was amazed by it you
know even though I kind of remembered
that you had been there in five years
but there's just certain states they
just they just they don't give a [ __ ]
like when they see the Surgeon General
come on TV they just like I don't
recognize that uniform he ain't no
[ __ ] Americans so they completely
ignore it so if you want to go back in
time with your child you know if you're
tired of reminiscing with your
adolescent son or daughter about how you
used to be able to go in a bar and I
have a drink and a smoke why not live it
why not go to st. Louis I think that
they should add that to their tourist
attractions right up there with the with
the arch the Gateway to the West
so to speak I actually hung around for
an extra day yesterday and I went to the
the st. Louis Rams game first the the
the Carolina Panthers and as boring as
part of the game was it was kind of
exciting to watch a team that you could
tell was gonna be [ __ ] good in about
a year or two the ramps remember you
heard it first
November 1st 2010 right here Sam
Bradford I think is the real [ __ ]
deal guys cool as a cucumber he's
driving the damn team down the field
even though his top three receivers are
all out for the season
he was throwing it to white guys all day
long that's how many injuries they have
on that team they're all the way down to
the white receivers people and I know
what you're gonna say what about Wes
Welker all right Wes Welker that white
dude who played for Denver there's not a
lot you know but slowly but surely I
don't know if you've noticed the the
white guy is is is making a little bit
of inroads back into into some what do
they call those positions performance
our speed positions you know there's a
couple of white running backs did you
ever think you were gonna see that again
I mean I couldn't believe it I'm in st.
Louis people are smoking within
structures and there's a white
quarterback throw into a white wide
receiver
it was unbelievable if I was waiting for
Larry Csonka to come walking out on the
field with that little [ __ ] you know
the two bars across his face and then
that one the the the horseshoe he had on
top that's why I don't [ __ ] respect
the goddamn 72 dolphins they had two
white running backs okay and you know he
went undefeated did ya who'd you play in
the third week some group of people from
the [ __ ] YMCA you [ __ ] pricks
would you fourteen you fourth tell you
to do is win 14 [ __ ] games 14 games
season you cheap bastards
oh god that [ __ ] loss to the Giants
still hurts but you know what feels good
watching the goddamn Jets lose 9 to
nothing I love it I love it and here the
Patriots are right in a rebuilding
[ __ ] year we got a bunch of goddamn
kids playing defense we trade Randy Moss
all these [ __ ] jet fans a [ __ ] go
Oh with the Patriots [ __ ] quit with a
nervous they couldn't be to judge if the
game picked up David that's what a great
coach Bill Belichick is all right you
[ __ ] [ __ ] how do you like that
six and one with a bunch of children
playing defense
six and one best record in the NFL I
don't know how the [ __ ] we did it I got
it I gotta admit I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna believe that we're actually gonna
do something and unless we we beat the
Steelers and we play the Steelers in the
Jets and even if we go one and one if
we're competitive then I'm gonna get
excited but uh you know I don't know
with our defense at this point is half
way to be in good I feel but I'm telling
you don't sleep on the [ __ ] Rams I
should have bet those sons of [ __ ] I
should I had no idea what was going on
down there in st. Louis and they got
that maniac the [ __ ] is his name number
55 that kid from Ohio State god damn it
what the hell was his name something
itis
dad's like a professional wrestler he
went in and he got a sack and he did the
[ __ ] Hulk Hogan you know putting his
cup in his ear and then he did the
flexes and then the I was great it was
[ __ ] great I don't know what the Jets
lost
I'm so [ __ ] excited cuz all those
[ __ ] and you know it's funny I
didn't get one
goddamn [ __ ] email from any of those
goddamn jet fans who've been giving me
[ __ ] all these weeks you know idiots
they're not idiots you know what they
are they're hopeful sons of [ __ ] they
haven't won in 40 years they get excited
about little things like drafting
[ __ ] Mark Sanchez Sanchez you know
what's gonna be the end of the jet
season if one of your unbelievably
awesome offensive linemen goes down with
an injury that [ __ ] goddamn mediocre
overrated jackass overrated this week
Marc [ __ ] Sanchez that game managing
jackass good lord
[ __ ] sitting behind the goddamn
Berlin Wall you could have [ __ ] rex
grossman in there and he could throw for
a hundred eighty yards no pics you're
not impressing me speaking of that man I
had the [ __ ] red I got my ass handed
to me yesterday
thank God I picked the Dolphins I had
the Dolphins getting one in Cincinnati
and I love the Dolphins I love them they
got that [ __ ] defense and the Bengals
went sputtering all [ __ ] year so I
said [ __ ] it I'll take that so I won
that one then I had the Redskins Donovan
McNabb going in to play the Lions but
typical me I don't read up on sports I
didn't know that their quarterback was
coming back for the Lions I don't know
what his [ __ ] name is Stafford
something like that I had no [ __ ]
idea and then when when the whole games
on the line included my [ __ ] money
you take Donovan McNabb out and you put
in Rex Grossman the guy the cult
secretly [ __ ] paid off the Bears to
be quarterback so Peyton Manning could
finally get his [ __ ] ring after they
went into the goddamn rulebook and
changed the rules so Peyton could
[ __ ] actually beat the Patriots in
the [ __ ] playoffs playoffs whatever
I'm just talking
[ __ ] I actually took the Colts tonight
as much as I hate it I'm gonna have to
[ __ ] root for the Colts cuz I could
go up to games on Paul virzi who almost
went oh and for last week mister I know
sports Paul versio you listening he went
one in three yesterday and I uh I've got
one or two but I have the Colts tonight
loving them loving them to avenge their
loss to the Houston Texans I don't even
know what the [ __ ] spread is cuz I
don't give a [ __ ] I really don't give a
[ __ ] I just like pissing people off
let's get let's get on with the podcast
it is November 1st everybody and did you
guys all have a nice Halloween did you
have a nice Halloween dude did Brett
Favre die yesterday did you guys see
that [ __ ] Jesus Christ he looked like
somebody kicked him in the balls from
behind the way he was laying there with
his [ __ ] knees up to his dealer who's
gonna get an enema it's like what are
you doing dude dude you own every
[ __ ] record out there good and bad
what are you going for the mediocre ones
now I don't understand this guy it's
just just just walk away I don't like
how he's patting himself on the back too
you know I got hit and uh that's a hit
then you know I don't think a lot of
people would have got up from but you
know I had on some Wrangler underwear
and I just said [ __ ] it
he is a tough son of a [ __ ] but you
know I don't know what he's trying does
his wife hate him at this point
yeah I keep playing I don't give a [ __ ]
showing your dick - everybody [ __ ] you
oh here's something I actually I never
even addressed
alright Brett said that that annoyed me
and Kobe Bryant a couple months ago when
LeBron was doing his big decision thing
when he finally decided to go to Miami
Kobe made this statement I figured if I
brought this up they asked Kobe if he
would have done the same thing and he
goes no I wouldn't I would have stayed
and I thought that was kind of kunti
it's like well that's easy for you to
say when you [ __ ] play for the Lakers
and they bring all the free agents to
you you know
there's been no reason for you to
[ __ ] leave your whole [ __ ] career
they've been bringing you guys you were
playing in Cleveland you would have left
Kobe you almost left cuz you didn't like
Shaq either he goes there I go
I'm sick of where the championships
there's a [ __ ] career they brought
you Shaq Dennis Rodman Phil Jackson
caramel own Gary Payton Robert Horry Pau
Gasol
[ __ ] that dude who choked the people
I died off I don't watch [ __ ]
basketball who's that guy there uh Jesus
Christ he's do a bit of bottom I say his
name every goddamn night he was Jermaine
O'Neal slid across the floor punch that
guy in the face
yeah whatever the [ __ ] his name is
Luttrell's [ __ ] third cousin they've
brought you a list [ __ ] free agencies
your entire goddamn career I thought
that was a real [ __ ] I move for someone
who is allegedly LeBrons friend but how
funny is it watching
LeBron's people sitting there trying to
do damage control with these stupid-ass
[ __ ] commercials trying to get people
to I don't know what changed their
opinion about him I mean I could really
give a [ __ ] it's just like just [ __ ]
go play basketball I don't give a [ __ ]
what would I do like what would I what
would I do I would I would not even be
able to make it on my eighth grade
basketball team if I remember correctly
so I I don't know what I would do LeBron
I haven't had to make decisions like
anywhere near that level I don't care I
don't care about you and yet talcum
powder and your little [ __ ] ritual I
could give a [ __ ] just [ __ ] go out
and entertain me I don't need you to try
to redo your [ __ ] image you know I
don't know so what you can make a
hundred billion dollars don't you have
enough isn't it enough you get free
sneakers I don't even know what I'm
talking about people I'm just [ __ ]
thinking about all the [ __ ] I have to do
for the rest of the day that's what I'm
doing in this podcast right now I'm
cleaning the dirt out of my keyboard and
speaking of what you know what I'm dying
to do I'm dying to [ __ ] replace some
of the tile in my bathroom
you know this is the latest thing I'm
obsessed with I'm obsessed with learning
how to fix [ __ ] around the house because
I'm gonna buy a house and I'll be [ __ ]
if I'm gonna pay some [ __ ]
mouth-breathing jackass with Dickies
hanging off his goddamn ass to come in
there and overcharge me for parts cuz he
wants to have a [ __ ] kegger that
weekend you know so if you want to learn
how to do [ __ ] right I think this is you
do it you do it in the apartment that
you live in it see like my dog clawed up
some of the some of the trim around the
door and that's a [ __ ] joke
I'm looking at it going this is this
this can't be this [ __ ] difficult I'd
go down to Home Depot
they got pre-cut [ __ ] down there so all
I got to do is get the [ __ ] that's the
same [ __ ] size I trim it off the
bottom make sure it fits
slap it on there right who cares if I
[ __ ] up it's not my place it's all a
little bit of pain over it
nobody's gonna notice my landlord
doesn't listen to this podcast does he
no seriously I want to I want to learn
how to [ __ ] do that some of that [ __ ]
already know how to take a toilet out
can take the whole [ __ ] thing apart I
know how to take a [ __ ] sink out now
I don't know how to do that [ __ ] I just
watched a couple of YouTube videos but
it gave me confidence I'm confident with
the sink that you you [ __ ] set down
into the counter that one that you got
to go underneath with I don't know how
like that's when you're dealing with
gravity I like the one that sits down in
if you could just unhook everything and
then figure out how to hook it back up
later you know you got to turn on the
hot water and all of a sudden the
garbage disposal goes on in the [ __ ]
kitchen I want to learn how to do that
[ __ ] but uh I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about alright let's let's
let's let's get to some YouTube videos
of the week people shall we um first one
and these are all gonna be on the the mm
podcast.com the official website of the
Monday morning podcast that is back on
iTunes as you heard earlier with my
horrible singing um alright here they
all are and these aren't these aren't
even YouTube videos these are videos
that I got everywhere but YouTube
because everybody's on YouTube so I'm
trying to go a little bit outside the
box with some of the [ __ ] that people
send me this is one
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] to call
it just go to the mmm podcast.com and
check this one out a buddy of mine
stand-up comedian Rob Cantrell [ __ ]
hilarious really original guy comedian
and I think um I think what's the first
season on Last Comic Standing he was on
that's the first time I saw him and I
was like I like this dude because he
doesn't seem like he's trying to win the
competition as much as he's trying to
give these people some quality stand-up
and then you had the other guy [ __ ]
going around with the goddamn Ginsu
swords [ __ ] spinning it around so of
course America votes for him right
that's how they do it
give me some shiny [ __ ] that's what I'm
voting for
he did a thing about why pots should be
legalized in this country he made a
great [ __ ] video that's supposed to uh
it's supposed to be like the beginning
of that movie Patton check that one out
there's another one dude with nub Kade
Kos another guy it's a guy with yeah he
has only one arm and then he has part of
another arm and he [ __ ] he's in I
don't know what they're doing Muay Thai
and he Muay knocks the other guys
[ __ ] ass down out of the camp canvas
next one is touch my body
karaoke fail with some English subtitles
even though the guys singing in English
and the last one actually comes from a
dude who runs the mmm podcast ooh if you
want a real if you want some advice on
gambling this is the guy he's on a
[ __ ] hot streak crazy racist in
coffee shop starts yelling at Mexican
dude so there you go there's your videos
that you can watch while you're at work
or working out or whatever I got a lot
of emails last week from me imitating
those dudes on the corner so kawaii bad
that [ __ ] remember that last week
somebody said that impression of the
street preacher with the bad PA was
spot-on and [ __ ] hilarious there's a
guy shouting in Spanish into a blown-out
PA on the weekends in my neighborhood
this
two churches
there's two churches on every block and
even the immigrants immigrants residents
even the immigrant residents this is all
the misspelled here immigrant residents
grimace and give him dirty looks how do
you say quit shouting and fix your
levels in Spanish that is a reoccurring
thing that I have found straight across
the board when people go out I don't
give a [ __ ] black white Latino Asian I
don't give a [ __ ] they never have the
levels correct in their PA I think
they're so passionate about their
politics that they never really uh I
don't know and it's such a grassroots
actually when you think about it do you
really think Obama knows how to use a
mixer how old is he yeah he probably
doesn't he's like [ __ ] I don't know
how old the guy is I have not paid
attention to politics in
I don't even know when I have no [ __ ]
idea when I just I wanted whenever I
stopped talking about conspiracy theory
a theory because I just got so depressed
about all of the [ __ ] you know started
reading up on banking like here's uh
here's something interesting here I this
is one way I kind of see both sides of
this this guy sent me this letter he
said that bill listen to this [ __ ] so my
wife and I are looking at buying a house
like you I am NOT the biggest fan of
banks so instead of putting all my money
in a savings account I have been saving
some cash on the side and keeping it in
my dresser yeah there's a smart place to
put it why don't you stick it in the
mattress there's another place you know
dude if you ever had that money stolen
by somebody breaking into your house
that burglars should have been dressed
up in the black and white striped shirt
with the Lone Ranger I'm a [ __ ] bank
robber mask maybe maybe you're just
saying you put it in your dresser you
actually put it somewhere else you know
you got a cut you got to be a little
more creative than that
anyways he says well when my wife talked
to the bank about getting a loan they
asked us our incomes how much money we
saved and how we would be paying our
downpayment my wife sold in about our
savings and everything was fine she then
told him that I had cash saved up on the
side they immediately stopped her and
said that the cash could not be used
unless there was an explanation for how
I got it and a paper trail to back it up
the bank's look at your financial
history bank statements and your
spending habits to determine if you
really could save however much cash you
actually have since some of my money is
cash
I've won from poker games and old stuff
I sold on Craigslist Craigslist
I have no paper trail for it the only
way that I can now use it for our house
is to get my parents to lie and write a
note explaining to the bank that they
gave me the money as a gift and I'm not
sure if that will work because I don't
know if they will check my parents bank
rest records to confirm that the whole
policy is [ __ ] I understand that the
banks [ __ ] up
and had to foreclose on a lot of people
and they want to make sure that I'm not
paying for a house with drug money but
come on this essentially means that if
I'm walking down the street and find
$20,000 in cash in an alley take it and
try to use it as a down payment the
banks won't let me because there's no
record of how I got it this whole ordeal
really pisses me off and I'm pretty sure
it goes back to what you're trying to
say about how the government is trying
to phase out cash money no that doesn't
that's that's one of those double
standard things that they do where you
have to produce all this paper trail
stuff to show that you're not a piece of
[ __ ] but they on the other hand the
Federal Reserve I'm talking about
they've never been audited and we gave
them a trillion dollars bailout money
and it just disappeared into thin air
they can't say who got it or where it
went and they're not being audited but
you on the other hand you know you sell
an old skateboard and your original
[ __ ] PlayStation you win some money
down the street in a poker you know a
poker tournament none of that [ __ ] you
know you're supposed to pay taxes on all
of that [ __ ] and if you found 20 grand
coming down the street what you're
supposed to do you're supposed to report
it bring it down to the police station
okay and hope that those [ __ ] guys
don't dip into it and I guess after a
certain amount of days it legally
becomes yours but then you have to pay
taxes on it and all that bit all that
[ __ ] and all after the fees you're
probably left with anywhere from 8 to 10
grand that's how you're legally supposed
to do it and what's annoying to me is
that you and I are up what we're held to
those legal [ __ ] standards but banks
are not
banks are supposed to be watching our
money keeping it safe and they for
basically I don't know how many goddamn
years
we're loaning it out to [ __ ] homeless
people given six-figure loans to them
and lo and behold when these [ __ ]
people defaulted on their goddamn loans
and the whole thing went into the
[ __ ] the government [ __ ] bails
them out they're like we're too big to
fail they [ __ ] bail them out they
keep the bailout money and now they they
added all these kunti surcharges to
urine your account and my account
so yeah that's I don't know this is what
you this is what you do with you if you
have cash on the side use it for [ __ ]
that you can actually pay for in cash I
guess I mean or save it in case your
bank ever goes goes belly up and there's
a run on your bank you won't be sitting
there with your pockets turned inside
out going can I at least have some
yogurt but yeah it is practically the
more you read about banking you'll start
to understand why corporations and
and/or super-rich like you know the
entrepreneurs why these guys have
offshore accounts and all that type of
[ __ ] because these guys basically I
think read up on banking which you would
have to you read up on the tax laws and
you see how the whole game is played you
see who gets penalized and who doesn't
and you start thinking Jesus is [ __ ]
ridiculous
so let me get this straight when I get
to this level of wealth
all of a sudden rules don't apply to me
okay well let me work my ass off to get
to that level oh wait I can't cuz they
keep taxing the [ __ ] out of me oh I get
it I got to do some there will be blood
[ __ ] I mean I'm really overly simple
simplifying the whole [ __ ] thing but
that's basically how it goes down I mean
that Bank is not gonna take that risk on
you you know I got some cash on the side
that's actually good banking you can't
have somebody just come in and be like
hey listen I got to be really
stereotypical now I'm gonna be Italian I
already [ __ ] on [ __ ] southerners why
not do an Italian stereotype hey I got I
got I got good credit and I got ditch I
got this 50 grand on the side where did
I get it hey why don't you let me worry
about that all right you know I you know
somebody else actually sent me something
about banks here hang on one second let
me read this and annoying more people
actually majored in economics or
economics however the [ __ ] you say it uh
here we go here we go let me read up on
this [ __ ] here you guys getting bored
with this [ __ ] well I don't give a [ __ ]
alright
I do give a [ __ ] if I didn't care I
wouldn't be asking but I'm gonna
continue hey Bill I've been thinking
something about something you said about
taxes on your podcast it was about you
trying to build build up a pile of cash
and how the government government's
hitting you up for tax money at every
opportunity yeah that's my thing I'm
trying not to put money in the stock
market I'm just trying to stick it in
the bank or whatever and they just taxed
the living [ __ ] out of me but if I stick
it on the crap table right
which the [ __ ] stock market is if I
throw it in there then they have no
problem with it then all of a sudden
they give me a tax break hey get over
here and play the [ __ ] game Oh so
anyways that's anyways let me get back
to this um they're hitting you up for
tax money for every opportunity but that
there are rich [ __ ] out there who've
already got there so they don't want to
get they don't anyone to get rich after
them there really is something to that
yeah they got a key they got it they
have to keep you did they can't have
people making [ __ ] money and actually
being able to keep it because if they do
then nobody would work we would just
[ __ ] kick back and relax and maybe
have a chance to enjoy ourselves maybe
sit by his stream in the lotus position
or whatever the [ __ ] it is you want to
do they want you to run on the wheel
until you're [ __ ] drooling and then
they want whoever you created to then
take care of you in a nursing home and
then if you can't they just want you to
die um I Twitter something wrong okay I
tweaked I twigged I didn't what that
means I tweaked on to this about a year
ago when I was having a discussion with
a friend about progressive income tax he
seemed to think that it takes from the
rich to give to the poor and the
progressive income tax is
anti-capitalist it's not though because
I don't know what the [ __ ] any of this
means here because earned income tax are
always higher than rates on dividends
and capital gains income I mean I got I
can read that much slower because earned
income tax rates are higher than rates
on dividends and capital gains income
okay so basically money that you already
have that's being invested the tax rate
is lower than someone who's out there
earning the non working air or heiress
who survives on dividends and capital
gains from a family fortune like a Paris
Hilton their income tax is at a much
lower percentage than a working person
with an equivalent income so basically
if you're sitting around in your ass
you're some [ __ ] luck lucky rich kid
the money that you're that you basically
inherited
you are earning off of the there will be
blood great-grandfather that you had the
tax rate will be lesser for the Paris
Hilton kid than someone like me if I
could earn if I was earning that same
amount of money does that make sense
makes sense to me I hope I explained
that in a way you understand all right
the system punishes work and reward
rewards ownership with tax rates that
provide incentives for one kind of
economic activity over another i basis
on my experience with my
kanae this guy Ralph with my the
Canadian system and before I emailed you
I had to use Wikipedia confirm to
confirm that the u.s. system works
pretty much the same way and right there
this entire email gets thrown out the
window Wikipedia sir what are you [ __ ]
me maybe it doesn't make sense on the
podcast let's go with this Wikipedia
information the worst part of it is that
by implication work is less valuable
than capital the woman making $8 an hour
at Walmart is paying the same percentage
of income tax as the wal-mart heirs pay
on their dividends a medical doctor
however pays more than twice as much and
the doctor is patching up the sick and
wounded the incentives in the systems
are all wrong so you're basically saying
the borderline poverty person and the
rich people are paying the same amount
of taxes and the guys in the middle me
are getting the [ __ ] taxed out of them
yes exactly exactly that is my [ __ ]
life god damn it I have to hit pause
here people I I got it I got a blow my
nose hang on a second all right I'm back
sorry about that you know what happened
to me I was eating a bowl of wheat Chex
too fast and I didn't chew up the wheat
Chex enough so they went down and was
like swallowing chewing tobacco and it
got soda like it was just like a bunch
of like you know was in the back of my
throat so I was like did that and it
some of it went up into my nose so I was
actually wheat Chex
[Laughter]
wine I'm having a rough Monday you never
started your weed off your weed off your
week off with some wheat Chex in your
nose wheat Chex a healthy part of the
checks family let me tell you guys I'm a
big fan of the Chex cereal sound like
wheat Chex I like corn Chex
I don't like rice Chex
you know what I mean it's like a [ __ ]
bad movie
it's just weak it's just a weak cereal
you know I don't like those cereals that
are like oh my god milk that's what
that's what rice Chex does it just
[ __ ] eejit call it's a it's a
quitting cereal you know corn Chex has
some fighting them
coin checks are like the Jets we checks
are like the Patriots we checks our
course the strongest hey you green
[ __ ] you lost this week how do
you like that 9 to nothing I love the e
overpaid for your [ __ ] tickets and
your brand new [ __ ] subletted
apartment with the that the Giants own
you know why they roll out a little bit
of jet signage do you really think that
you own 50% of that do you really think
that you sons of [ __ ] what was it
like to go to that boring ass [ __ ]
game kick 3-nothing je t s what the [ __ ]
another couple of [ __ ] hours of
boring football kick
6-nothing je t use what the [ __ ] right
kick 9 nothing go home did the firemen
cry this week oh I love it
overrated talking [ __ ] before the season
even starts like you just won three
Super Bowls in a row underrated having
your stomach stapled Rex Ryan is getting
better-looking every [ __ ] week
son of a [ __ ] kinda has a jawline now
doesn't he alright just to be fair I got
to make fun of Celtics fans overrated
Channing overrated when you're up by
11:00 with eight minutes left against
the Miami Heat
did you guys watch that game then all of
a sudden they all stay started roaring
back and all the felt Celtics fans just
shut the [ __ ] up
and then once the game was was decided
with 12 seconds left they started
chanting overrated again that was a real
[ __ ] [ __ ] mood that was real [ __ ]
yeah that I didn't I didn't I was
embarrassed to be associated with that
franchise alright who's the [ __ ] who's
too started that chant
um alright that was if that was just a
quick little riff of underrated
overrated underrated having your own
[ __ ] jet airplane with a big bed in
the back in a giant seat belt you know
beautiful woman to sit on your dick and
a [ __ ] IV to put you to sleep you
just wake up in New York that's all I
want that's all I want
yeah that's all I want out of this
business Sony I don't need much I gotta
fly to New York people I'm going to New
York on Tuesday night take the red-eye
back to that [ __ ] and I'm doing
a benefit for the troops playing the
Beacon Theater with believe it or not
this is this is the lineup on this show
it's going to be beamed to three
different bases in Iraq and three
different bases in Afghanistan John
Stewart is hosting
Tony Bennett
is I'm assuming he's singing I don't
think he's doing stand-up Jerry Seinfeld
Bruce Springsteen
michail
myself
couple of other people all I'm doing is
eight minutes but uh I can't wait man
it's gonna be uh well I don't I don't
wanna do the flight but it's gonna be
[ __ ] awesome that's Wednesday I'm
flying out that's why I'm telling you
got all this [ __ ] to do today because I
got whoo
you know I just landed here last night I
got do the [ __ ] podcast I have an
audition today I'm pitching a [ __ ]
show today I got to pay my [ __ ] bills
it's the first on the month I got to do
all that [ __ ] horseshit and then I
got to jump right back on a plane
tomorrow you know it's one of those
[ __ ] weeks speaking of that dude I
flew out to st. Louis last week and
there was some woman who was clearing
her throat like twice a minute from like
I would guess about Utah - Jess into
Kansas
she had this exact same way of doing it
and I swear to God I have never prayed
for my own plane to crash before but
that was one of those moments I didn't
want it to crash you know I was just
fantasizing that like there was a crack
in the fuselage you know and it she that
woman just got sucked out so as I was
fantasizing about this is how [ __ ]
crazy I took it I actually reached down
and I tightened my seatbelt and I
mentally went over how to put that
[ __ ] mask on my face before I helped
the infant or child next to me I thought
you know it was really disgusting the
way she was clearing a throat she was
talking really loud on her cell phone
just everything about it was annoying
and whenever I see a person like that
the first thing I do is I look for a
wedding ring you know and when I don't
see one I think thank God and when I
when I do see see one I actually feel
bad for the man a woman that is married
to that you know how could just like
and actually I came up with like a
philosophical question you know that
those dual psyche commercials the most
interesting man in the world what do you
think would happen here's one for the
the pot smokers out there all right what
do you think would happen if the most
interesting man in the world met the
most annoying woman on the planet all
right I want you to know I want you to
tell me what you think would happen
because I couldn't come up with an
answer to that question you know he is
the most interesting man in the world
well I would like you to meet this [ __ ]
who was sitting diagonally [ __ ]
behind me oh speaking of that underrated
[ __ ] movie macGruber does anybody
rent to dead I don't know if you'd be
happy if you paid to go see it at a
theater but [ __ ] you know unless you
have a silly sense of humor like me cuz
I would enjoy that if I saw it in the
theater look at me even though I try to
compliment something I say in a dick way
I think this is a funny [ __ ] movie
with a couple of really insane
monologues in it and not to ruin
anything
spoiler alert spoiler alert I had to
bring this up the last name of the the
bad guy in the movie is [ __ ] and I'm
assuming it's spelt with a kk u NT Z or
something but it's you know we got we
have to get [ __ ] I don't know it's
sophomoric it's [ __ ] hilarious it's
one of those movies you want to watch
with the female in the room because you
just be going this is stupid I think
this is funny oh my god that's grouse
which will just make it so much more
funnier macGruber two thumbs up for me
baby
alright this podcast is all over the
place let's move on to the next one the
advice section why you would ask me for
advice I don't know okay here we go
I started listening your podcast about
three months ago and I really liked it
thank you I was inspired to buy a couple
year albums on iTunes thank you now if
you ever hear me bitching about people
[ __ ] downloading [ __ ] I'm not talking
about you or being cheap [ __ ] it's not
you buh buh buh
comedy my whole life and recently I sat
up and went onstage for a five-minute
spot for an open nut open mic night at a
local comedy club here important
Portland I was really impressed by the
people that showed up many of them were
talentless dickholes but at least they
have the guts to get on stage and for
that they deserve some credit well thank
you sir
thank you for [ __ ] extending that
olive branch to them so I got up there
in front of a whopping 15 people one of
which who was my girlfriend and talk
some [ __ ] it was I was pretty nervous
but my voice was steady and I was
energetic but most importantly I got
people laughing there you go it's all
you got to do it might not seem like
much but I I had a high like no other I
might stick with it basically I write
down a few prompts
now this isn't me people I swear to God
I know I suck at reading but just the
way that some of this [ __ ] is written
I'm gonna read this basically the way
this guy wrote it or actually exactly
the way he wrote it I might stick with
it basically I write down a few prompts
out for stories and quips and go to town
I feel like open mic nights might be the
only way to get some chops doing my bits
for friends or to into a mirror doesn't
have the same effect as a bunch of
strangers I'm gearing up to put some
hard work into my act I would like any
tips on how you get you got your chops
and how you practice your act all right
couple things yeah yeah you can't run it
by your friends to do it in the mirror
you can maybe say it a few times in the
way of the club just so you can kind of
get the flow of it but yeah the only way
to do it is to do open mic so you know I
would do that just do that and I would
also drop the attitude that people who
are starting out are talentless dick
holes they're not they're [ __ ] you
know if you saw me when I started out
you would have thought that this guy
sucks because I did suck because I was
brand new at it so you don't want to do
that and for all you know the those
air-quote talentless dick holes will
someday be in a position in this [ __ ]
business where they could actually hook
you up with something so I cannot stress
how important it is to have good
relationships with fellow comedians and
everybody in this [ __ ] business that
you can I'm not saying that you take it
to the point that you relax you actually
allow somebody to walk all over you and
treat you like [ __ ]
I'm not saying that but don't walk
around judging people
but a [ __ ] thing cut out on me again
god damn it I'm sorry I've been I'm
putting together new our comedy and I
have a bunch of stand-up sets on my
[ __ ] recorder that I never end up
listening to something else sir that you
might want to do if you're doing
stand-up is to record yourself and
listen to yourself so you can become
better as a comedian but the key is you
got to listen to them anybody can record
them and then just leave them on their
[ __ ] tape player or their [ __ ]
digital recorder whatever the hell you
call this goddamn thing yeah that's what
I would tell you that man seriously like
you will be absolutely [ __ ] amazed
with with the people that you think are
gonna do something and don't and the
people who you like that person I don't
know I don't think they're gonna do [ __ ]
and all of a sudden they're directing a
movie they're the head writer on
something they create a show who knows
what you don't know what anybody's gonna
do so yeah you know so I wouldn't walk
around I mean I'm sure you just write in
that maybe to make me laugh or something
but I'm just putting that out there
all right because I've seen people act
like [ __ ] and then get treated
accordingly by these people that they
thought were beneath them or whatever
it's it's just the worst [ __ ] thing
that you can do in any any in life in
general treating someone else like like
[ __ ] or whatever I don't I don't
understand why people it really makes
your life a lot more difficult and
someday when you die you know like
there's gonna be people only people at
your funeral is gonna be you know the
[ __ ] - guy the guy who drives the
truck and the guy who digs the hole or
the hearse I should say yeah so that's
that's the advice that we give you keep
doing the open mics keep writing stuff
tape record yourself and you know and
then and then be a good guy be a good
guy but then you know be a good guy
within reason I mean like I said don't
don't don't take [ __ ] from people and
then also try to try to be hanging with
the
people who seem the most motivated most
positive that type of [ __ ] because
you'll get caught up in it and and Yatta
Yatta [ __ ] yada that's basically it
so we're coming to the close here of the
podcast another kind of short one this
week just because I do have so much [ __ ]
to do here congratulations to the
Rangers and the Giants for your first
World Series Giants are up three games
to one and I was getting nervous for
giant fans I actually I don't mind
Ranger or the Giants I have no problem
with neither one of them but I was
getting nervous for the giant fans when
they were up two games to none and then
the Rangers came back and won one game
and I was like God in a lot of ways the
Giants are kind of like how the Red Sox
were except they're in the National
League you know how the Red Sox were
back in the day where it was not only do
they not win they have to rip your
[ __ ] heart out too and I don't know
at the risk of pissing off Ranger fans I
think the giant fans said I think
they've had
I think they've had about enough I think
it's time for the sports gods to let him
up off the mat give him a goddamn World
Series and Ranger fans who you kiddin
who were you honestly [ __ ] kidding you
know you're all Cowboy fans you know if
the Cowboys record was flipped right now
and Tony Romo was living up to the
potential you know you know you wouldn't
be selling out those World Series games
now I'm gonna [ __ ] you I'd like to
Ranger sense [ __ ] who was that who
was that [ __ ] who was that guy buddy
something or buddy Bell that come here'd
jackass who played third base um he's
not a jackass it just sounds funny I'm
trying to think of guys who played for
the Rangers when I was growing up
the [ __ ] was it somebody wrote something
funny on the internet about how ten
years ago when the Rangers signed a rod
to a two hundred million dollar contract
he vowed to one day lead them to the
World Series and when he struck out
looking on the New York Yankees he
finally delivered on that promise Oh
bill you're such a [ __ ] I know I am I am
a [ __ ] I actually watched the Patriots
game in this the sports bar in st. Louis
and there was this [ __ ] old guy in
there who was basically he had like like
nine sports buttons on his shirt he had
this little glow stick with him
and he's one of those guys when he
yelled but it still wasn't loud he just
kept going
whoa the Patriots were the Cheetahs but
we always win and everybody was ignoring
them and anything the Patriots did was
awesome like this guy's [ __ ] shanks
this punt right right up the side of his
foot for the Patriot as the ball is
dropping to his foot the guy's going oh
what a kick whoa pissing off everybody
in the sports bar but he's too [ __ ]
old to punch in the face but this is
what killed me about this guy was
the people around me Joey he [ __ ]
comes here every week he's unbelievably
annoying and the worst thing is is he
has he's fans of like six different
football teams like he's a fan of the
Patriots the bills and the Dolphins
they're all in the same [ __ ] division
and he's a fan of the Kansas City Chiefs
so the Bills played the Chiefs so no
matter what he can't lose and he just
sits there the whole game oh what a
throw
Oh what an interception like he just
wants to win the entire [ __ ] time
long story short I had to take a picture
with the guy because he started off cute
you know what a cute old man and then at
one point if I was if I was drinking I
would have engaged with this dude during
the second quarter and been like hey how
the [ __ ] can you be fans of every
[ __ ] team you old [ __ ] I would have
done that but fortunately I'm not
drinking so it took me until the fourth
quarter where I started to give him [ __ ]
but then in the back of my head I was
like really bill are you really gonna
get into it with this old guy but by the
end of it he was just kind of hilarious
so I actually took a picture with the
guy and I'm gonna have that uploaded
onto the MM podcast.com and what else do
I got I got a pipe a few gigs here
before I before I sign up from this bar
this podcast was an absolute [ __ ]
I apologize I had high hopes for it but
you know like a lot of things in life it
just doesn't work out um what do we got
here all right I'm gonna be at the funny
bone in Columbus this is really one of
these podcasts that I would have stopped
and restarted ten minutes into it but I
just don't have the [ __ ] time all
right bill we've heard your excuses you
have to mop your kitchen floor nobody
gives a [ __ ] all right I'm gonna be at
the claw uh the funny bone in Columbus
Ohio Friday Saturday Sunday November 12
13th and 14th and I'm gonna try to go to
that Ohio State Penn State game that's
my big I don't want to be bored shitless
at the mall in Columbus move then I'm
gonna be making the following week I
will be in Washington DC at the Lisner
auditorium and that's on a Friday
November 19th on November 20th Oviatt
comics at Foxwoods in Connecticut I get
a lot of emails from people from
Connecticut being like do when he coming
[ __ ] Connecticut I'm gonna be there
it's a beautiful new room everybody's
been raving about it all the comedian's
who performed there so come on down
check out my new hour and then finally
this is the one I need your help on look
into your hearts I am playing the more
theater in Seattle Washington all right
for those of you unfamiliar with the
more theater it is a legendary theater
in Seattle Washington
I guess what rock fans grunge fans
remember that Pearl Jam video I think it
was even flow well even Pro when Eddie
Vedder is climbing out into the crowd
and [ __ ] jumping off the balcony and
stepping on people's heads and [ __ ]
that's where they filmed that and I have
to sell a lot of [ __ ] tickets I'm a
third of the way there so if you and
some of your drunk buddies want to come
down for the love of God please come
down to the show because I got a ton of
tickets to sell and in Clear Channel I
don't know what they've done to radio
but they've they've taken off you know
my guy up there was Marty reamer which I
heard he has a podcast now if you live
in Seattle [ __ ] those radio stations
that took him off listen to his podcast
because hopefully I'm gonna be doing
that to hype my show I'm kind of running
out of ways to hype shows now with what
they're doing to radio for those of you
out of the loop I think Clear Channel
basically wants to have four deejays for
the entire country and you walk into
these radio stations now they don't even
have a receptionist they have an
automated system for you to figure out
how to get to where you're going out on
that's you know yet another thing and
I'm sure you people who are all for
these kinds of technologies like I love
when people like try to support those
automated checkout lines like they
always say the same thing you know and
you stand there looking at this poor
bastard behind the [ __ ] Reggie you
mean that person with the [ __ ] job
you really want to see him be a poor
bastard what would you rather be a poor
bastard behind a [ __ ] cash register
or a poor bastard you're [ __ ]
homeless and don't have a goddamn job I
hate when people do like dumb [ __ ] like
that just to try to enhance their
[ __ ] point if you [ __ ] believe in
that technology support the technology
don't start saying what the person
behind the [ __ ] register is thinking
even though I'm doing the same goddamn
thing but I think I can go out on a limb
and say that most people would rather
have a [ __ ] job than be homeless
alright a lot of yelling this week bill
as opposed to what every other quiet
week and then the final two gigs of this
year before I take my month off and I
begin my martial arts classes joking I'm
gonna be a cobs comedy club in San
Francisco December second third fourth
and fifth and I'm gonna be at the improv
in Brea California the 16th 17th 18th
and 19th of December come on down this
new hour is starting to take shape
actually at some guy come up to me this
weekend in st. Louis and was like that
was absolutely hilarious I didn't think
it was as funny as let it go but III
liked it it's like thank you sir well
it's not done yet you know thank you for
starting to compliment me and then
giving me a little dig hey you look
great you're not as fat as you used to
be um all right and this guy hey he
really had a pudgy face they really did
he had one of those he was a white dude
but he was like so fat he was starting
to look Asian
you know nummy when you get so fat your
eyes like that that precious girl you
know you know when the fat just starts
building up on your cheeks all of a
sudden you know that's how you start to
look
we're not being an incredible way to
sell some fat-burning products are you
so fat that you're starting to look
Asian in your eyes even though you're
not well listen that is offensive well
line up behind the Italians and the
southerners that's what this podcast was
this week I'm trying to get fired from
my own podcast I'm trying I want a lot
of complaints and have people say that I
need to apologize to different groups of
people so that I can be fired from my
podcast because I think I need a [ __ ]
vacation from this [ __ ] I really do
no I don't actually love doing this [ __ ]
I just got too much [ __ ] to do this week
so that's it that's the end of this
[ __ ] podcast I'm uploading it I
apologize for my singing I apologize for
the scatterbrained podcast that this was
but I think I think I like to think that
there was some moments it was a good
rental anyways that's it and thanks to
everybody who's been buying the the old
genius ringtone on the mmm podcast if
you want to donate to the podcast $0.99
look into your heart go to the mmm
podcast.com and download the oh Jesus
ringtone I'm actually getting a new cell
phone this week I was gonna try to hold
out for the new iPhone when it's uh not
the new iPhone the iPhone when it
switches over to Verizon but my
blackberry is [ __ ] the bed I can't
get emails on it and the letter n
doesn't work anymore unless I [ __ ]
sprained my thumb pushing it down and I
think I'm gonna get that droid phone
what do you guys think about that one is
that a good one
I want Verizon I want to stay with with
Verizon cuz as far as where I travel I'm
gonna get the Droid I should just gone
out and got in the [ __ ] thing and
just had you guys [ __ ] all over me that
it's a bad goddamn phone as opposed to
now where I'm gonna get like 50
different opinions like dude do not get
the Droid
it [ __ ] sucks get this phone yeah I
have Verizon keep that in mind suggest a
smart phone for me okay that is it thank
you one and all I hope you guys have a
great goddamn week and
and that is it that is it that is the
parties as Christ what a horrible ending
and that is it
really bell really yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you